Once we have printed out our current information, we read a command, we're going to define
appropriate function input command for that and then we're going to invoke a function named debug
with the command with the current argument and with all local variables.
We have our debug function--return a value named resume.
If resume is false, we stay in this current event--that is we don't proceed in our code,
and if resume is true, then we exit the loop, step out of our trace it function
and then execute the next line in the program.
Let me first come up with the debugging function.
It accesses the state of the debugger by these two global variables--stepping and breakpoint.
If the command we have entered as an argument, then this should be a space between the command
and the argument and we get the argument by splitting the entire string,
getting the second element in the resulting list, which is the argument.
Otherwise, the argument is just none.
Now, we can check what the command actually is and what it should do.
For instance, if we say s or any command that starts with s and want to step to the program,
so what we do is we set stepping to true such that in the next line the program will stop again
and we return true such that after stepping,
execution resumes and actually goes to the next line.
We can now add more commands--for instance, continue here which sets the stepping variable
to false and still ask the debugger to resume.